Speaker 1: All right. Let's now move on to the one
year anniversary of the January six Trump riots,
a year minus a day ago, being January 5th.
This was January 6th of last year. Many of us,
about one and a quarter million of you, tuned
in to pieces of my coverage of the Trump riots.
It feels like it was yesterday. It's now been a
year in that year. We have seen hundreds of cases
against the rioters move forward, who were clearly
Trump supporters. We have learned more about, yes,
the plan, the plan, the expectation, the
hope from Trump and Trumpists that this
or anything would prevent the certification
of Joe Biden's win on January 6th and Donie
O'Sullivan. Or don't I forget exactly how it's
pronounced Donia Donnie from CNN. He's excellent.
He went and interviewed Trumpists one year on from
the Trump riots. Have they come around to reality
in any way on what took place? Have they accepted
that it was Trump people who did the rioting
and Joe Biden did win the election? They have not.
This is one of the most stunning if there were
a sociological time capsule to look at
a thousand years from now. This video
should be on it. Let's jump right into it.
Speaker 3: And your sex attack was not the
Republicans, nor Trump. It was. The Democrats
were behind it all. They're the ones that caused
it all. Do you really believe that? I know it.
And there is no way that a Republican would act
that way. And there is no way that Trump had
anything to do with what happened on January six.
Speaker 1: This is the no true Scotsman fallacy.
This is, by definition, the rioters couldn't have
been Trumpists because no Republicans would
ever do that. It's a closed loop. It's dark,
sarcastic closure. It is an India feasible
statement. Call it whatever you want.
You cannot reason people out of that belief
because there is no reason as to why they
hold it. You just can't do it. By definition, the
rioters weren't Republicans because Republicans
wouldn't riot. Wow. Strong statement
Speaker 4: But what about all the Trump
supporters that have been charged and indicted
Speaker 3: because it's all Democratic judges and
people that were on the take from the Democrats?
Speaker 4: It's been a year since the attack on
the U.S. Capitol and because of disinformation,
denial and diversion, Americans don't have a
shared history, a shared understanding of what
happened here on that day. Also, I think the
Speaker 5: whole reporting of it is a
giant hoax. We are very peaceful people.
So it was a total setup to me. It was the
FBI had set it up. I don't believe that
they were Trump supporters that did that right.
Speaker 4: The whole thing's a setup. You don't
really believe that, do you?
Speaker 2: I do.
Speaker 5: I do. Because Trump
won the election. They, they
they they've proven it over and over again.
Speaker 2: I really don't think Trump had
much to do. Other people that were
supporters for him somewhere involved,
but I think they were enticed by the FBI.
Speaker 1: This is why I say we have to
take very seriously the possibility
of something even worse in 2024.
Listen to what these people are saying.
There's no there's no entry point
to disabuse these folks of these false beliefs
Speaker 2: and by by, you know, undercover agents.
Speaker 4: Dear God, when I spoke to Trump
supporters here in Washington on January 6th,
most were in denial about the results
of the 2020 election. Do you accept
that Biden won the election?
Speaker 5: No, absolutely not.
Biden did not win this election.
Speaker 4: On January six, we walked
with Trump supporters who marched from the White
House, where Trump was doing his speech here to
the US Capitol. And as we arrived here, that is
when the first security barrier was breached.
At the time, some Trump
supporters told me they were happy
with what happened here at the Capitol.
Speaker 2: Are you proud of what happened
here today? Absolutely. I think we should have
gone on and yanked our senators out by the hair,
the hair and drag him down and said no more.
Speaker 1: Now understand that. Now they say no
Republican would ever behave that way. Anyone
who did that stuff wouldn't be a Republican.
And yet, a year ago, here are Republicans
saying we should go in there and drag
senators out by their hair. So are these
the people that are the fake Republicans?
Speaker 2: I'm absolutely stand behind 100 percent
what happened here today, 1000 percent. And it's
terrible how this election was stolen.
Speaker 4: Federal prosecutors have charged
more than 700 people in connection with the
Capitol rice and repeatedly documented the
rioters support for President Trump. But
some people in right wing media have pushed
the dangerous idea that it was all an FBI.
Speaker 2: Plus FBI operatives were organizing
the attack on the Capitol.
Speaker 4: There is absolutely
no evidence whatsoever that this was some kind
of false flag event staged by the Democrats or
the FBI. What would you say to people who say
January 6th was the biggest attack on American
democracy since before rubbish? But amid all the
denial and deflection, I met one Trump supporter
who said it was important to be real about what
happened on that day. What do you think of the
Trump supporters that stormed the Capitol?
Speaker 5: Oh my God. You talk about Miss
Miss found feelings seeing the folks from my side
of the state that were there, and they're not the
part of the campaign that we would like to have.
Speaker 4: Do you think some Trump supporters
that say it's antifa, it's Black Lives
Matter, that they know that that's bullshit,
but they just don't want to admit
it's easier to blame someone else.
Speaker 5: Everyone is afraid to, you
Speaker 1: know, take the blame. And so that last
point is an important one, and we've talked about
it before. Do these Trumpists literally believe
that Trump won and that the rioters were
antifa and the FBI? Or is it something
they say to signal that they're on the team
and they accept that sometimes in a war,
you've got to tell lies or whatever because of the
greater good? We don't really have the answer to
the question. The answer is probably some of them
really do believe it. But some of them understand
that in order to show that I'm on the team, it's
what I've got to say. One year later, and it is
as bad as it has ever been, which should really
scare us about 2024. Let's take a quick break. You
can find me on Twitter at De Packman and let me
know your thoughts about these incredible videos.